[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
him Sydney pal is just a coffee
girl he doesn't know who in the hell
City pal
is he's never been my attorney ever in
the the history of ever ever even though
I tweeted that she was my attorney and
then she went out into a press
conference that's my attorney what the
[__] is wrong with these people how can
they believe this absolute garbage whoa
is that it's it feels like something's
going on here feels like something's
crazy here hang on a second let's
see no it seems right that's right
that's right it just it feels I feel I
feel like I don't know yeah let's it
feel huge on the screen am I
wrong I don't know something's going
crazy today I'm super Tony today
speaking of super Tony did you see my
article on
patreon it's it's by iony it's a it's an
AI version of me that's
right I'm gonna put out AI articles a
lot of people might be upset about it
but you know we're going to be very
transparent about it I'm going to talk
about that today as well as Donald Trump
controlling the house speakership
they still have not found a speaker
apparently there's you know last week
there was only one only one person who
does not report sex crimes who was
trying to be speaker this week this week
there's all kinds of them like they
couldn't find one person besides the guy
who looked away at Ohio State as his
student athletes were being sexually
molested in the
showers but this week there's nine nine
now I don't know if they do the hide
their ey when that kind of thing happens
I'm sure they do it's their Republicans
but we'll find out we'll find out soon
enough rather there is going to be a
naring of this now we also have some
audio and I don't know if I'll be able
to pull certain clips of this audio but
apparently George Santos Matt gance and
Lauren
bobert were in a Twitter space this
weekend and they let the cat out of the
bag that they don't want the government
to stay open and that it's inten that
there's not a speaker because that's
really uh we were just talking in the uh
patreon only producers corner on Discord
this morning we were just talking about
this very issue which you should think
about joining us on Monday mornings and
Friday morning it's an hour before the
show we have great conversations in
there H you get to come up on stage you
can talk to everyone you talk to me uh
and it's just more personal than than
anything and it's a great conversation
we always have great conversations on
Mondays and Fridays but people were
talking and and they were talking about
and I believe it was Nats girl was
asking um rather I believed that they
would shut the government down and I
said yes they are absolutely going to
shut the government down I've been
saying it all along that is their goal
the reason why Kevin McCarthy isn't the
speaker of the house is because he kept
the government open he made a deal and
kept the government open even just for
45 days it was a step too far to keep
the government open for 45 days and
Donald Trump got rid of Kevin McCarthy
and the reason why they can't get a
speaker the reason the reason why they
can't function is because of Donald
Trump that's the only reason that's the
reason why they can't function because
it's authoritarian right something it it
definitely is bigger right am I not am I
crazy am I crazy something I don't know
I might have to restart my [__] but
we're not gonna do it right now we're
gonna keep going we're gonna keep going
here we ain't gonna stop just because my
head looks
huge doesn't it am I crazy
it looks I look [__] huge here it's
way zoomed in I I don't know what the
hell's going on I tried to fix it but
you know what are you gonna do oh I can
I can touch up my appearance how does it
look now do I look good huh do I look
better does that look better oh look at
that what the hell some sort of it's
like some sort of AI [__] makes me look
smoother makes me look like I got smooth
skin do you like that or should I go
back to just regular here's regular
here's a regular as we say it you know
you know when you're a kid you had
uh you'd have like you your grandpa want
cigarettes you want Menthol or you want
regular I'm just take those regular
cigarettes regular the regular ones
anyways uh yeah Shelly Says Baby Face H
Tony Lake hey that's a good that's a
good point it's some sort of um yeah
carry lakish is what they're saying okay
well you know what we we'll go with the
Cary lakish and I can really Cary Lake
it up look at this look at this thing
o aren't I cute I don't know we're just
messing with [__]
now that's weird is't it weird am I just
am I crazy is it it looks weird yeah a
lot of people are saying um Tony Lake
speaking of Tony and different Tony did
you guys check out the I Tony um article
on patreon it's the first Terminator
type [__] that I've done so far so we're
going to be uh doing uh an AI
Tony Oley W says it's it's 1107 where's
Tony I'm right here can you not see me
or is it just that I look so smooth that
you don't actually see me is that what
it is I'm So Smooth that you can't see
me I don't know I don't know what the
hell's going on this morning I don't
know
I just go with the flow though you know
what I mean
um you guys are wild cameras don't Li T
you have smooth skin I don't really have
that smooth of skin but you know we can
fake it it's okay um Pig Step fan says
is this AI Tony I don't know you should
question everything you see so maybe you
should question if this is really me
since I'm So Smooth I'm like carry Leake
uh filter type smooth right now
so all right are we gonna move on to the
news oh by the way again if you guys
didn't see it I posted an article on I'm
gonna get rid of this I can't stand it
any longer there we go all right back to
back to
Old the Tony not AI Tony here
uh I don't need a filter I'm just that
pry I don't need no filter I'm pretty
enough uh so here's the thing is I
posted an AI article on patreon over the
weekend and it's an article about
Gabrielle Hansen the Nazi that's running
excuse me excuse me the Nazi adjacent
mayor candidate in Franklin Tennessee uh
and we're going to be we're going to be
publishing more and more articles over
there uh on on the patreon so and and I
posted it for free so if you guys want
to go read it you don't need you don't
need to be a remember to read it you
just got to follow me over there to read
to read the U to read the article so
just go go to the Tony michaels.com let
me show you that here uh I'm gonna get
it up here I'll show you where to go on
uh the Tony michaels.com so that you can
go find this thing here it is this is
Theon michaels.com just hit subscribe up
here at the top and then you pan down
and it's the patreon page is right here
and it says follow patreon for free
follow on patreon for free just click
there now if you want to be a paid
member that would be great that's like
how I make the microphone stay on is you
guys you guys keep this microphone well
you usually can see it today it's I
don't know what the hell's going on my
head's so [__] big uh maybe I'll
scoot back here is that better there
maybe that'll work now I can't reach my
[__]
anyways patreon go to patreon you can
read that very first article uh from I
Tony the AI Tony it is an AI Tony brain
that we're making that's right so what
is going to happen is you're able to
submit stories and here let me show you
that you're able to go to the Tony
michaels.com right now and you can go
down to submissions and you can submit a
story just click on this it'll take you
to a form that you fill out you just
need your link the link to whatever
story you're going to have and I Tony
will actually start writing stories on
these things that that's right you pick
you
decide what iony reports about now it's
not
perfect yet okay so you gotta bear with
us because I Tony the AI Tony doesn't
say the FW that much we got to teach him
how to [__] cuss you know what I mean
I mean I had to learn how to [__]
curse too this is a thing that I had to
do so we got to teach the AI Tony how a
[__] curse but he's starting to talk
about it in our name so
um H some people are saying I should
borrow the chair that uh speaker mcbo
tie when I get a smaller chair and I
look smaller I don't know I promise I'm
not doing any kind of camera tricks to
make me look bigger like Patrick McKenry
would would want but any who any who so
yeah if you go to the Tony michaels.com
you can submit a story there and we will
we'll see if AI Tony can do a story on
it and it'll get better and better and
better So eventually it'll get kind of
crazy and this is why I'm trying to be
transparent about it because there's a
lot of AI going around especially with
like the conflict in Israel and Gaza um
there's a lot of misinformation being
dumped on the internet and a lot of it
is produced by AI believe it or not and
so um you know you got to question
everything you see everything you see
you should be questioning it uh even if
it's me on the show with the big head
and you know a Cary Lake baby face
filter kind of thing you know what I
mean wink wink I really didn't plan that
I would have a filter today when I'm
talking about AI Tony but I guess it
works oh boy but AI is coming and
actually it's not coming it's already
here so um and we're going to be doing a
lot of different things with AI for you
guys to engage right so we want to build
some tools for you guys to use like meme
makers and all kinds of crazy stuff but
one of the things is this submit a story
because we want to give you guys the
ability um to actually have ai Tony
write stories for you um so they'll
write stories they'll get published and
then you'll be able to go to the link so
that's why it's so important that I'm
going to put these on patreon for right
now eventually we'll be putting them on
a website but for right now we're going
to put them on patreon so just scroll
down to memberships follow on patreon
for free it costs nothing to follow on
patreon and really honestly uh if you do
support me there thank you so much it it
it it is it is the biggest help to keep
this microphone on like that's the thing
that keeps the show going is your
support rather you're doing uh venmo
super chats uh which I actually got one
over the weekend or if you're uh buying
shots Jennifer sent me uh one and says
cheers to the loudmouth person that you
are love it listen to you listen um it's
it's uh she
said and she's also on patreon so thanks
Jen uh for your super chat over the
weekend um but um you can also support
by buying shots on the Tony michaels.com
so I appreciate all that support that
that means a lot to me um but more than
anything we want you guys to engage your
democracy I got to turn the filter off
again this is yeah I'm I'm not into it
at all how does carry Lake
how does she do that like want to
be all smooth and [__] you know what I
mean you know what I mean but let's get
back to Donald Trump Donald Trump claims
he doesn't know who Sydney pal is and
Sydney pal is never his attorney even
though even though Donald Trump tweeted
that she was his attorney and then and
I'm going to show you a clip and it's
similar to the clip that um I showed you
last week where she was speaking as his
attorney at that press conference where
Rudy giuliani's brains was [__] out
of his skull and it was running down his
face you remember that one where the
[__] was running you know again like I
say everything Trump touches turns to
liquid [__] and Rudy's
brain eventually turned to liquid [__]
and it was just dripping down his face
so that's how it works I guess I don't
know we live in a new age nowadays um
but but here's the thing
is that uh Donald Trump's not going to
be able to get away with this as far as
like lying to us now again like I
normally say he's not lying to me and
you right because we're smart enough we
got enough [__] brain cells to rub
together that we can figure out that
he's full of
[__] pretty much everything he says he's
full of [__]
right but here's the thing he is lying
to his base he is trying to keep the
manga sheep in a herd and the reason why
is because now the manga sheep are like
whoa wait a second wasn't Sydney pal his
attorney and now she's turning on him
because and she's admitting to election
fraud and election interference wait
isn't that what she accused Democrats
and Hugo Chavez's ghost of like
literally they're they're you know qan
on is really [__] confused I mean
they've always been confused let's face
it they're really [__] confused now
though they can't figure this out but
this this is why you can't keep [__]
lying in politics I mean yes you can you
can lie about certain things and get
away with it and you can mislead
constituents and get away with it but
you can't make fundamental foundational
lies and just keep piling them on top of
each other eventually it's all going to
come crack ing down to the [__]
ground now we're not to the crashing
part yet I I hate to be the bear of bad
news here we're not at the crashing part
yet if we were at the crashing part yet
they would have a [__] speaker of the
house they would tell Donald Trump where
the [__] to go and they would just elect
someone to be the leader of their
conference like the majority is supposed
to do but they don't have a majority
folks the Republican party has a
majority but they don't
and the reason why is because they're
not actually a party anymore this is why
it's so important for people to
understand our two-party system and how
our democracy Works our Democratic
constitutional republic for all you
[__] [__] eating MAA out there that
don't know that a constitutional
republic can be a democracy I've been
getting that comment a lot on YouTube
here this morning there's a video that
we made because I say it all the time
that manga does not believe in democracy
because they don't and all the [__]
comments that they drop on this video
prove that they don't believe in
democracy and the reason why is we were
talking about it in the patreon uh
producers corner on Discord this morning
the reason why they don't believe in
democracy is because it doesn't suit
their needs anymore right it doesn't
suit their needs anymore they can no
longer force you to do what they want
you to do with democracy because democra
democracy has advanced so far that uh
people are like yeah so what if you want
to marry whoever the hell you want to
marry who [__] cares if we want to
all get together and make sure that
school lunches are provided to
kids who the [__] cares if if we all get
together and decide that no one should
go broke because of a medical bill in
this
country like literally if we all get
together and do that democracy can do
that for us right
because we are the government in this
Democratic constitutional republic
that's how it actually [__] works
right we democratically elect people
through a constitution to go represent
us which is called the
Republic how the [__] don't they know
this they do know it but again the
problem is is they don't want democracy
they don't want it because they're
authoritarians it's the reason why they
can't select the speaker of the house
there's only one dude that controls
their party and they don't even have a
party
anymore Donald Trump the reason why all
this is happening all of it the reason
why I have to sit here and talk about
Sydney pal the reason why I have to sit
here and talk about day after day after
day after day after day about how they
can't select the [__] leader in the
house it there's only one reason it's
just [__] one it's just one one
reason Donald Trump Donald Trump now
some people are saying Putin in the chat
which yes but Putin Putin is a Chaos
Agent Putin isn't directing all this
stuff to happen I don't believe that
Putin is some sort of [__] you know
pulling puppet strings I know that they
know the reason why they have a lot of
power is because Vladimir Putin has used
has used Russian social media Bots to
[__] brainwash some of the cult and
that's where it's led to But ultimately
it's Putin likes Trump because Trump
means chaos right he means cha I mean
Jesus Christ the guy was given a gag
order last week he breaks it within a
couple days the judge finds him $5,000
now who could have seen that coming uh
you know a lot of people act like they
they were going to toss him in jail if
he broke a gag order which was [__]
ridiculous they were never going to
throw him in jail I still don't think
they'll throw him in jail for breaking
the the the gag order I think that's all
kind of ridiculous to think there's a
two-tier justice system for sure in this
country and Donald Trump H has benefited
from it almost his entire life up until
the point that he tried to overthrow our
government and commit a goddamn Cheeto
dust kangaroo coup that's when it
stopped really protecting him the way
they wanted it protect to protect him
that's why they're so [__] pissed off
that's why they're so desperate to win
and in their desperation to win Donald
Trump believes his own
[__] that if he shuts the government
down then they won't be able to
prosecute him and the economy will go to
[__] and Joe Biden will be blamed for it
you know that's why he wants the
government shut down he wants your
economy to be [__] he wants the United
States economy to
crash he wants your [__] livelihood
to crash he wants your retirement to
crash he wants your income to go away he
wants you to lose your job so that he
can blame it on Joe Biden so that way
that [__] can be president of
the United States again so he can save
his own ass which is not a thing that's
gonna happen because we the
Democracy it's not a democracy Tony stop
saying that you're hurting my
feelings our democracy is what stands in
the way of these fascists taking over
our [__]
country
so if if he wants to shut the government
down that's what he's gonna
do because he rules their party he is
their Clown muga
King he's the Cheeto dust
qanon he is going to shut the government
down it's wild stuff to watch it's wild
stuff to wrap your head around
but it's G to
happen we've been two weeks without a
[__] speaker actually three weeks
without a [__] speaker you think
we're going to get a speaker within
three weeks you think they're anywhere
near getting a speaker of the
house [__] the last guy Jim Jordan that
they took to the floor three times and I
believe he's going to be their next so
they're going to go through this process
of this week of trying to pick out
between these nine [__] losers of
who's going to be the king loser of
these [__] losers and they're going
to go back to Jim Jordan because Jim
Jordan's really the only one that's
willing to do the job because he loves
power I mean he do like to do anything
he don't like to work once he gets it
but you know he'll pretend he'll act
like he he's working he'll roll up his
sleeves and he'll he'll adjust his tie
to make it look like he was doing hard
work this morning as he was on the phone
with Donald Trump taking [__] orders
from the King
clown that's it folks and I I I know
that I'm the bear of bad news here and I
know that sucks but what what else do
you want me to tell you do you want me
to say oh no it'll be fine they'll
definitely find a speaker don't worry
folks it's we're gonna what they'll do
is do some madeup [__] that isn't real
and make Patrick McKenry the speaker
that's really dumb [__] I don't know
where people are getting getting that
people keep saying that that Patrick
McHenry is going to be somehow the
[__] the temporary speaker he already
is the
protim he can open the floor to vote for
speaker and he can then go to recess if
there is no
speaker like that's the power that was
given to him by the rules when Kevin
McCarthy was
vacated he doesn't have the power to
bring a vote to the floor without being
speak
and he's not speaker and to change the
rule of him being speaker protm to to
inter term or whatever the [__] they
want to call it he would have to change
the rule I don't see how the [__]
they're going to change the
rule they can't do any business that's
the whole [__] point of the
process government is supposed to be
slow I don't know if you know that
either it's supposed to be gear grinding
and the reason why it's supposed to be
gear grinding is so they can't just
[__] take over swast the power folks
the reason why these rules stand in the
Republicans way is because they got to
do what we the people want them to do in
our constitutional republic that's how
it [__]
works there's documents there's
procedure there's law standing in their
[__] way from taking power now you
might say but Tony they have power yeah
but do they do they really have power
what are they doing with their power if
they do have it are you kidding me
actually the point is they don't have
any power they're powerless they're
effectless you couldn't even reason with
them if you wanted to so I know it feels
bad that they're going to shut down the
government and they're not going to do
the work that the people sent them there
to do
but America will pay attention and
they're going to know and they're not
going to blame this [__] on Biden Biden
ain't got nothing to do with this
[__] and it's obvious and it's G to be
more and more obvious and folks I want
to prepare you because I I actually
don't know when they'll be able to have
a speaker as long as Donald Trump says
no you can't shut the you can't get the
government open there won't be a speaker
that will open the
government there won't be
period And I wish I had some clips of
the because I I got well we got the
audio uh from Santos Matt gats and
Lauren Bower uh talking over the weekend
how yeah we're going to shut the
government down that's the whole [__]
point we don't want the government
open and Donald Trump's at the heart of
it folks that's what we that's what
we're dealing with is a Republican party
is dead and what is left of it they're
authoritarians and they are listening to
One dumb [__] who believes his
own garbage in his puny little brain
that somehow shutting down the
government is good for him and he
doesn't give a [__] about anyone else no
one he cares about no one but himself
and he literally believes that what he
can do is he can shut down the
government
to suit his needs oh Shaz is back oh B
Shaz Max is back on Facebook welcome
back shz boy are we gonna have a good
time
today ah you [__] idiot I'm glad
you're back I missed you you stupid son
[Laughter]
[__] oh everyone getting the comments
on Facebook give me some stars on
Facebook did you know you can give stars
on Facebook dud
give some Stars that's a good way to
give support to the show also you can go
to Twitch and link your Twitch account
to your Amazon Prime account you can do
that it's free of charge it doesn't cost
you a single thing you get one free
subscription with your Amazon Prime
account you can link it to your Twitch
account which gives me you know a couple
bucks a month to keep this microphone on
and golden and I appreciate all the
venmo super chats if you guys want to
give a venmo super chat or you want to
buy me a shot you can go to the Tony
michaels.com
right now that's Theon michaels.com but
you really should you really should go
to Theon michaels.com why we're at the
break and go to patreon and follow on
patreon it's free and you should
download the app even if you have to
download the app on your phone and
follow it doesn't cost a dime to follow
because I'm going to be pumping all
those AI articles once we get it you
know situated and figure out how it's
all going to work we're going to be
pumping those AI articles over on
patreon so make sure to go follow on
patreon again if you can support us on
Pat patreon that would be great you
there's a five a 10 a 20 memberships and
some higher ones if you do the $20
membership you can get in on Discord and
you can get in on the early Monday
morning meeting and the early Friday
morning meeting we do a meeting an hour
before every single show it's called The
Producers corner so get in on patreon
get over to the Discord don't go
anywhere though or or if you're gonna go
do that come right back because we are
going to be right back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy there's Tammy by the time we
reached DC we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way we we got plenty of slim gems
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again here's Bob dear Bob I'm
fixing to send you some more of them
Doritos you like the red bag not the
live loving blue one in your absence I
discovered a rash on my neck and no it
ain't no hickey and I ain't even seen my
cousin Brody in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours Tam
me [__] them [__] [__] them [__] [__]
them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast oh welcome back to the show
looks like Shaz Max has invited his
stupid ass friends to the chat on
Facebook Facebook welcome you dumb [__]
eaters welcome to the Tony Michaels
podcast boy we're going to have fun with
you today you're never gonna want to
miss an episode you're never gonna
you're gonna be [__] you're gonna be
[__] Facebook famous after
this I have a picture I have a picture
just in we have a picture of the Kraken
the Kraken is trying to escape from jail
now here is the
Kraken trying to figure out how to
escape from the situation that you're in
release the
Kraken get the Kraken out get the
cracken
out I don't know Shaz you are stupid son
[__] I love you so much man I love this
Shaz guy over on Facebook I know a lot
of people over there get tired of him
but you know he doesn't say too
outlandish stuff he says some really
stupid [__] though I just sets the ball
up on the tea for me it's so easy I
can't wait to boot
Biden he was saying I'm GNA Peach Biden
hey Shaz guess what you're gonna want a
speaker first before you can impeach
bad impeach tree dish Biden
Shaz Shaz you need a speaker first
before you can impeach Biden which I
would advise that you guys get a speaker
that would be great if you could do that
the rest of the country will be waiting
um while the clown car that you have
elected and you keep promoting in this
chat can't find a leader other than
Donald Trump and he won't actually be
speaker right so that's the problem that
they're having is he won't actually be
speaker but the other problem that
they're having is he's kind of a [__]
for
brains no literally he's a [__] [__]
for brains he acts like and we're a [__]
for brains too and it's really not it's
really not us like he's not saying this
[__] for us okay I want to be clear he
he's saying this [__] to convince dumb
[__] like Chez on on on
Facebook
right yep see here he is see Trump for
Speaker of the House impeach Biden lock
up the cile old man so impeach Biden
then lock up Trump is that what you're
saying I don't know maybe that's what
you're saying it depends on how you
interpret
it oh my [__] God this guy this guy I
I don't know if he's a bot or not but
I'm telling you um it's a hell of a bot
if it's an AI bot Chaz I don't actually
think you're real I think you're an AI
bot but it's a good one I wish I had you
know I don't know 30 or 40 of you
honestly rat rat can we can we can we
make can we make some ignorant Trump
loving Bots can we do that can we makes
some ignorant like you know like
convince sayi that they're just sheep
and they're dumb as dog [__] can we do
that can we make I AI really think
they're dumb and believe all kinds of
Lies like Q andon lies and just come in
comments and say all kinds of crazy [__]
is that a possibility I don't know I
don't know we should check in on that
thank you rant we should
check this AI stuff is crazy I'm telling
you you have to question everything
everything everywhere H and I question
this rather this was real but Yep this
is on his true Social account it is real
Grandpa poopy pants denying that he
knows Sydney pal at this point which is
[__] hilarious and the reason why
it's [__] hilarious is because cydney
Po and Kenneth cheeseboro have now pled
guilty to misdemeanor and felony charges
for election interference the [__] that
he accuses Democrats of the [__] that
that he pukes up and then Chaz comes
here in the Facebook comments and he
pukes up Chaz and his friends should we
we need to get a name for Shaz and his
friends friends you know what I mean
like like a band name you know if like
Shaz was in a band what would the band
name be you know that kind of thing and
I know some people like Tony you're
punching down at Shaz in the comments
but I love Shaz I'm not punching down I
thought he' came here to you know have a
little fun let's have a little fun you
[__]
idiot oh yeah she she you know you know
you're right you're right say cdy pal is
an and is an American hero She Went Down
to Georgia and now has admitted that she
tried to commit election interference
six charges by the way six Char and
she's gonna have to testify against your
[__] musolini Jesus Donald Trump she
really is an American hero she went down
to tried to steal elections in the name
of Donald Trump you are such a [__]
idiot how in the hell don't you shots
shot shotsies yeah someone on um on
Twitch sha shazis sh schis schis schis
schis shis I don't know shis schis
that's what it should be
schis
schis poor shz and hisn shz and the
schis oh my
God again I actually Pro I don't
actually I'm beginning to believe that
Shaz is not real right it can't be it
can't be it's got to be a [__] bot
like a AI bot that just says this stupid
[__] like it takes it takes my voice it
transcribes it right and then it's like
oh yeah we'll spit this stupid [__] out
in the chat and then the bot types the
stuff in the chat and hits send so like
we're talking to these [__] Bots and
even if he isn't a bot even if he is
real which I highly
doubt is it is it any better
that he's real I mean this is [__]
real does this make it any better Donald
Trump says Sydney pal is one of the
millions and millions of people who
thought thought he says who thought and
ever increasing num still think they're
just
thinking there no proof correctly oh
yeah oh yeah I'm got to add that
correctly that the 2020 election was
rigged and stolen stolen I don't know
what Stalin is I guess that's what you
do when you go down to Georgia you try
to manipulate machines in Coffee County
you stallen the election and our country
is being absolutely destroyed because of
it yeah because of the election
interference and the election
lies it absolutely is being destroyed by
Donald Trump and his allies and [__]
eaters like Shaz it says despite the
fakes news reports to the contrary and
without even reaching out to ask the
Trump campaign
myth pal was not my attorney and never
was well [__] me
running Grandpa poopy pants that Sydney
pal is not his [__] attorney and
never was [__] me
running I guess we just got that [__]
wrong when Donald Trump I don't know
tweeted that [__] out that's right
Donald Trump tweeted that Sydney po was
his [__]
I'm not making that [__] up either I
again you got to question everything and
you know what question me and go try to
find it if you need to but here if you
can't let me give it to you here here's
the
Tweet 1011 p.m. he was on the [__]
one night after having a batch of
tacos on November 14 2020 and he tweeted
I look forward to Mayor Giuliani
spearheading the legal effort to defend
outright and I to free and fair
elections he's yelling and screaming
into the Twitter machine at this point
he said Rudy Giuliani Joseph GI D
Giovani or G Geneva sorry Victoria tonen
cydney pal there it is cydney pal and
Jenna Ellis a truly great team added to
our
other our wonderful lawyers and
representatives yes he did say oh yeah
we're going to have a legal team and one
of the lawyers is going to be uh Sydney
pal what the [__] does he think we're
this stupid or does he think Shaz is
this stupid surely he believes Shaz is
this stupid
right surely this has got to be he
believes Shaz is this because Shaz is
definitely this stupid like Shaz you
know I like you buddy and I want you to
keep coming here
but it's really dumb to believe believe
that Sydney pal is an American hero
because here she is his attorney acting
as his attorney he's saying it out loud
on November 14 2020 while he's taking a
taco dump on the toilet at 1011 p.m.
right he's painting the toilet with Taco
diarrhea you know that's what he was
doing he was on the [__] come on you
know I know you're like Jesus Christ
don't he has too much information but
you know what hey I'm just here for the
truth I'm just here for the
truth
but not only that not only that what did
he tweet it those stupid [__] stood in
front of a microphone and said it that's
right they stood in front of a
microphone and said it let me show you
here oh more evidence let's do it you
very much for
coming uh this is um representative of
our legal team we're representing uh
president Trump and we're representing
the Trump campaign wait wait wait wait
wait what did he say did he say I
thought Rudy Giuliani said that this is
a panel of lawyers that is representing
Trump and the Trump campaign it's almost
like Let Let me listen again you very
much for coming uhuh we're here uh this
is um representative of our legal team
yeah we're
representing president Trump and we're
representing the Trump campaign oh so
they're legal representation which is
called what the hell is that called well
don't go ask don't go ask sh he doesn't
know definitions he probably thinks
we're not a democracy so he doesn't even
know the definition of democracy so if
you're looking for
that what is the goddamn
word what is it what is it when you what
you call someone who legally represents
someone what the [__] is that
called oh a lawyer yeah that's right a
[__]
lawyer what the [__]
how it's it listen this is and I know
you're thinking Jesus Christ how can
people be this stupid they definitely
can't just go over to Facebook and watch
Shaz in the shot schatzis type in the
[__] on the Facebook Chat they can be
that stupid go look at the [__] go
look at the new shorts that we're
posting skip is doing a great job
cutting shorts and we're putting them on
YouTube of the show go take a look at
some of those things now you have to
manipulate it because YouTube is hiding
all the stupid comments YouTube is
hiding the stupid it's funny and someone
I think someone messaged Skip and told
him hey we can't see the comments of
these [__] eaters on on the shorts and I
was like um that's weird because I see
all the comments no matter how no how
much they try to censor them if that
makes sense um I see all of them or or I
can see all of them if that makes sense
but apparently YouTube it has a stupid
filter so anytime they see something
really stupid they filter it to where
you can't see it so you got to go like
select all comments when you're looking
at them you got to see them all all the
comments so I don't know but let's let's
see what else Grandpa FY Mardy had to
say here about the great legal team the
I don't know the lawyers that are
standing by him representing the what
the Trump
campaign oh when I
finish um Sydney Powell and then and
then Jenner Ellis will follow me oh so
Sydney pal is first up in the legal team
after Rudy
kudi so Rudy kudi first attorney second
attorney Sydney pal the one that Trump
says that he never had her as an
attorney what what even though he
tweeted it and even though they're
standing here saying it let's keep going
though let's keep with the evidence
maybe maybe some of the [__] eaters that
are listening to hate watching the show
can get with the truth and we will
present in brief the evidence that we've
collected over the
last I guess it is two weeks also Joseph
of jenev Victoria tending here with me
there are a lot more lawyers working on
this but we're the I guess we're the
we're the senior
lawyers oh he even says it he even says
that word the senior lawyers working on
this for the who the Trump campaign this
is not a far stretch right how the [__]
again though I know it feels like do
they think we're [__] dumb no they
think they think the shot shazis are
dumb they they they know the shart Army
is
dumb they know the shart Army and the
schatzies will believe anything that
they tell them anything it doesn't
matter and even if The Shard Army and
the
schatzis that's what it should be it
should be Shaz and The Shard Army right
that's that sounds like a pretty good
band name Shaz in the shart
[Laughter]
Army I actually I actually think shz is
real and I actually think that shz um is
actually here from the DeSantis campaign
because Ron is really [__] pissed off
that I predicted that he would lose he's
really mad about it that he didn't
listen to me and their campaign is
really [__] mad about it that they
didn't listen because he could have beat
Trump if he would have you know just
resigned as governor of Florida and ran
as right before Donald Trump was gonna
be indicted in New
York oh my God John says Shaz
GPT
that must be a new form of AI John I
think you're right it's Shaz
GPT as you guys know that's a that's an
open source AI that is out there that
people are using to build uh carry Lake
style models like this like this right
here like this
oh we got some AI we got some AI at the
Tony Michaels podcast now I'm all smooth
this is the smooth Tony um it's still
really me just
um it's just you know there we go back
to normal okay let's let's finish up
with Rudy kudi let's see if he says the
how many times he says the word lawyer
so we drink booze every time he says the
the word lawyer in this
clip and Boris
Epstein what we are really dealing with
here and uncovering more by the day is
the massive influence of communist money
through Venezuela Cuba and likely China
in the interference with our elections
here in the United States what in the Q
and on hell did she just
say it always gets me this is from 2020
like this is so far away from that like
this was so long ago but it feels like
yesterday doesn't it but this craziness
still gets you you're still like how in
the [__] are these people believe in
this crazy
[__] I mean listen if they were going to
make this happen this long ago then they
should have [__] got off their asses
a little more um we've got some we've
got some pictures here oh ah we got a
picture from the floor of the house it
looks like um Jim Jordan is running from
the manga King hang on a
second um I well you know what let's
finish up this clip and then I'll go to
some of these pictures on the house
floor we've got the manga King is on the
house floor so don't bear with me
here the Dominion voting systems the
smartmatic technology software and the
software that goes in other computerized
voting systems here as well not just Dom
minion were created in ven in Venezuela
at the direction of Hugo Chavez to make
sure he never lost an election after one
constitutional referendum came out the
way he did not want it to come out oh
Lord I wish we had like a like a sound
effect
like you know what I mean
like doesn't it feel like that's what it
feels like when you listen to this Q on
[__] and you thought I was crazy when I
would say this lady would [__] and moan
about Hugo Chavez like that's literally
what she's doing in this clip listen to
it again this is an official press
conference of the [__] lawyers that
the Trump campaign hired to represent
them
legally States the Dominion voting
systems the smartmatic technology
software yeah and the software that goes
in other computerized voting systems
here as well not just those electronic
computer thingies you know they got the
screens that you touch they're like
they're like sorcery and
stuff what and what about Hugo Chavez
tell us again Kraken Dominion yeah were
created in v in Venezuela at the
direction of Hugo Chavez to make sure he
never lost an election you know what I
want to point this out if you look here
in the back at at Jenna Ellis this is
the one now I don't know if Rudy's
actively farting on her giving her coid
in this clip probably um you know that
Rudy Giuliani farted on Jenna Ellis in
Michigan during uh some sort of [__]
stupid ass um we we had we tried to
steal the election and couldn't steal it
so we want to have a hearing about how
we tried to steal the election but
couldn't steal it and now we know in
Michigan they did try to steal the
elections with fake State electors uh
all 16 of them are charged in the state
of Michigan for trying to overthrow the
election um but Jenna Ellis here you
notice when Sydney pal is puking the
garbage out of her mouth you know just
[__] just puking up this vile stuff
out of her mouth she is like standing
there and she's trying so hard
to pretend to believe it she knows it's
all [__] that's why she's such a
[__] scumbag Jenna Alice now Sydney
Pal's brain might be such mush here that
she believed this garbage but Jenna
Alice you can tell she's working
overtime to [__] figure out how the
hell she's gonna act like she believes
this [__] you know what I mean and what
the hell was Rudy drinking people are
pointing out what the hell was he
drinking is that straight [__] vodka
or is that water is that Fiji Water or
did they replace it with something look
at this look at this guy
here and this is the press conference
where his hair was [__] I
believe
but okay well let's go to the house
floor I
guess I got some pictures from the house
floor here now let's see if we can bring
them up here on the screen the manga
King is on the house floor and he is
whipping his concus into shape to select
oh oh okay I thought this was here's the
maanga king here the maanga King clown
whipping what appears to be I don't know
if this is that Jim Jordan it appears to
be Jim Jordan and whipping Jim Jordan
into shape here so I don't know if he's
whipping votes for Jim Jordan or not
really sure I don't think they know what
the hell's going on over
there this AI think is fun it's G to get
funner I promise uh let's see we got
another image of the maanga king and Jim
Jordan and the Kraken apparently uh the
maanga king is trying to shut up the
Kraken here uh is and trying to make
sure the Kraken doesn't say
anything if like literally if you we're
rant are you typing in manga King and
this is what is coming up is that what
you're doing are you are you typing in
manga King and this is what they're
coming up with because it feels like
that's what you're doing you're typing
in manga and it literally is like oh
manga that's a bunch of
clowns that's a [__] clown car is it
is that what's going on
here oh my God this is I mean this is
what AI is coming up with when you type
in manga King is it's a Humpty Dumpty
clown with big ass clown shoes and a red
tie apparently a red tie here let me
show you there you go see there's the
manga
King it's going to be fun I'm telling
you so we uh back to to um the AI thing
real quick I know I'm jumping around
here but you got to question everything
to see if everything's real these days
and with this image of course you might
have thought when I said that I was
going to bring you images of the manga
King on the floor of the house right you
might have thought there might have been
some people in the chat that were like
whoa whoa whoa what's the news the news
is that Donald Trump is on the floor of
the house right because that may be what
you thought right now in this world
right now that we live in on the Tony
Michaels podcast I I I showed you this
image let me go back to it and I want to
give you an example here of how this
works and this is very [__] important
and I know this seems trivial because
I'm mocking Donald Trump here but just
imagine a world just imagine a world two
years from now three years from now
maybe six months from now literally you
could type that [__] in and produce an
image that makes it look like that what
I said the maanga king is on on the
floor of the house and all of a sudden
you have an image that may look like the
floor house you guys you guys were here
last week when I showed you AI Jesus and
you guys can go still see AI Jesus all
you gotta do is go to Twitch or YouTube
now YouTube it won't be a live thing um
but you'll be able to see videos of
it uh and you just type in AI
Jesus and it'll come up it'll come
up so
um let's
see looks like something's going on
let's see if there's something breaking
news here I'm just trying to keep track
of everything as we're going no okay um
doesn't look like too much breaking news
but um but soon soon possibly in our
universe that we exist in but we may not
really exist in because who knows what
reality is and who knows what the truth
is when you're looking at your phone is
that literally an image could be
produced that Donald Trump was on the
floor of the house when he really
wasn't and it could even be a video of
him on the house floor it really could
there's nothing stopping
it from being that way so when when I am
um trying hard to make sure that you
guys understand Ai and I'm being very
train transparent about it like I when I
produce these articles that are on
patreon and like when we're doing on the
show obviously we're joking right but
I'm telling you there is going to be a
time that we on the show here will be
able to produce almost any image that I
say and it will look as if it's real and
it could be produced now it may not be
you know a month from now or two years
from now or 12 years from now but
there's a point that it could be and I'm
I'm telling you I'm telling you that
that we have to question everything all
of it and I understand that you know
you're like well Tony you're actually on
the screen and the only way that I see
you is on the screen so should I
question you you probably should and
that's the reason why I want to make AI
Tony is so that you have to question
everyone it is so
important in the future the near future
that we do that that I think this is a
cause that we must get in front of and
it is to save our
democracy it is to save our democracy
that's the most important
thing that's what it's
about is to make sure we get out in
front of the lies the misinformation and
the only we're not going to get out in
front of it to to stop it from being
created we're way past that Rubicon we
are way over the Rubicon of stopping
misinformation and stopping lies from
leaking on the internet I don't know if
you noticed
that whoosh have you been on Twitter
lately holy
[__] I place a goddamn dumpster fire of
[__] fake and misinformation and it
made me think over the weekend because I
saw a video and I'm not going to show
you the video because I can't tell if
it's fake or not but it's really
incendiary and it's about the
uh oh [__] that's a good meme um I'm
looking at the Discord live show chat
and they're dumping memes in there and
they're beautiful if you want a cash of
memes just an unlimited cash of memes
you're gonna want to go to the Discord
by the way anyways anywh who back to the
AI subject um what was I saying oh yes I
want to be transparent about it and
that's why I want to post the articles
but I also we're gonna have an ey Tony
he's G to be on the screen
talking now at first that puppet is
going to look fake I I mean it's GNA
even look Faker than this um let me see
it's gonna look Faker than this even
right now I kind of look a little fake
right look like I'm Cary Lake here with
the Cary Lake filter but it's goingon to
be Faker than
this but it'll get
better like as the techn techology gets
better and Twitter is a dumpster fire so
there was a video that I watched over
the weekend and it was actually two
videos it was one video on top one video
on bottom and it claimed you know what
I'll show you let me see if I can
actually show you the I'm not gonna play
the video I'll just show you the
Tweet um that way you guys can see what
I'm talking about because I think it's
important and I know it doesn't maybe
feel like the news with the news that
we've gotten stuff that it isn't but
this is really um this one is [__]
wild stuff um and again I I had to
question it
immediately um to know if it was real or
fake let me make sure I've because I
want to pause it here because this thing
I I you know again I'm just not sure if
this thing let's see hang on a
second there we go that's the one we
want just gotta make sure I got in the
right one I gotta pause um but I'm gonna
show it to you it's from an account just
a [__] poster and I think they're
notorious for for posting just absolute
garbage uh Oli London is the name of the
account um and it it claims in the
Tweet he says video one is two female
Hamas terrorists waving guns okay and
video two is the same women pretending
to be victims of a bombing while dressed
as civilians on camera so here's the the
freeze frame that I've paused here of
these two women women and and what he's
claiming in his tweet is to they're
Hamas terrorists waving guns okay and
then in the bottom video it's claiming
that these are the same exact
women okay and that they're pretending
to be victims of a bombing while dressed
in civilians for the cameras
right
now I don't know what these videos are
real or fake okay now it could be either
way it could be that these videos are
real it could be now what does that mean
right that means one thing in the whole
you know commentary of the conflict
that's going on over
there and it it means a lot of stuff as
far as like what it actually means on
the
ground if it's real if it is real folks
and it could be it could be real but it
could be fake and you have to have that
filter now what if this is fake okay
let's just po postulate on that for a
second let's say that this video up top
is faked it's not really these women
they have pasted the faces of these
women and these women on these two
different videos that already existed
right
what is the consequences of that these
are questions we must ask
ourselves and that is the most important
thing is we have to ask ourselves these
questions but I'm going to end on a
lighter note okay because this stuff is
really
heavy
and I want to show you something that I
showed the uh patreon folks in the
Sunday rant last night with AI and a
lighter note because AI can be really
fun it can be really scary in this
instance where we have to stay very
Vigilant and we have to ask ourselves or
it can be super fun like when we're
creating
images or you know you just you're just
totally goofing on these idiots with
this stuff which we are totally going to
do I am totally going to make sure that
we
can that we can that we can Goof on
these some [__] now I want to show
you a total goof that is [__]
hilarious and I showed this last night
now this is AI that is called Trump
verse Biden right that's what this is
It's called Trump verse Biden it is AI
they are not hiding it that it is that
it is AI they're saying out loud that
it's Ai and you can tell that it's
AI but it's still [__] hilarious
watch this I'm gonna veto everything he
tries to do I'm gonna cut off his dick
and shove it up his ass so far he'll be
[__] out his own balls enough is
enough with this [__] for people
wondering this is GNA be a 247 stream
Trump versus Biden and the idea is that
they interact with the chat as well and
it's the presidential debate to 2024
pencil Bonine my favorite my pillow is
the one I use on your mother's bed
speaking of beds sleepy Joe probably
drools all over his pillow while
dreaming about China listen up Jack I
don't give a flying [__] about your my
pillow or your mommy's bed and as for
sleepy Joe he's not the one drooling
over China you want to talk about dreams
how about the dream that you won the
election fair and square you lying
cheating [__] [__] let me be
clear I'm not going to take any more of
this [__] from Trump I'm going to
veto everything he tries to do I'm going
to shut down all his stupid ideas when
it comes to his Web of Lies and
deception I'm gonna cut off his dick and
shove it up his ass so far he'll be
[__] out his own balls enough is
enough with this [__] it's dark
Brandon time
[__] it's dark it's dark Brandon time
[__] so look AI can be used for evil
or it can be used to laugh F your ass
off one way or the other we will figure
this out together here on the Tony
Michaels podcast so don't forget to hit
the Subscribe button you're not GNA want
to miss a single show as we roll out our
AI Tony I Tony for you guys rather it's
in written form or if we get one of them
fancy little puppets like Biden had
there don't go anywhere we'll be right
back with
more maybe news maybe it's real maybe
it's fake I don't know
we'll go through it right after this
don't go anywhere we'll be right
back we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy
pel's mail do you feel exposed to a
government that doesn't share your
patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered paron blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup Parton blanket will
protect you too Parton blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're 100% made in
the US USA don't delay and get your
pardon blanket today for just
$999.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast welcome back to the Tony mik
Michaels
podcast I mean as far as you know who
knows who knows this could be AI
too you should quit question everything
you see even here ony Michel as you know
that we welcome descent here on the Tony
Michaels podcast we always do and we
always will I'm okay with it God damn
I'm [__] huge today I don't know what
the hell I don't know why my camera
zoomed in I just feel like I'm humongous
on the screen here um there is
a
recording of uh George
Santos and Lauren bobert and I believe
Matt
gats in a room and I believe I believe
that I have a a recording of it here
let's see if we can go to this um they
were actually talking about the
government shutdown H we were talking
about this this morning this morning in
the uh let's see is this the right one
yes this is the right one okay um we
were I was talking about this this
morning in the early morning meeting we
have an early morning thing on patreon a
Discord that we do on the producers
corner now if you go join the patreon
and the $20 tier you guys can join the
early morning meeting and more and more
people are coming boy the crowd this
morning there was a lot of people in
there several people talking and they
were talking about one question to me
and I believe Nat's girl asked it if I'm
if I'm correct in that I believe that's
that's who asked the question um rather
I thought the government would actually
be shut down and I said yes I I not only
do I believe it I I think that's what
they want but here in uh a Twitter space
over the weekend I and I'm not sure
exactly who we're going to hear here but
it was Santos bobert and I and I believe
it was Matt gats in this um in this
space talking about this let's listen
and see if we can hear what they're
saying in this Ukraine frankly I haven't
shed the first tear yet that I haven't
watched members of both parties jump
over one another to send another 100
billion to Ukraine
and if shutting the lights off in the
house floor as we continue our oversight
work such that it's sincere and Comm
continue our committee work is that
people can't run up there and write
another big ass check to Ukraine well
might be a silver lining in a little bit
of constructive chaos there you go I
want to shut the government down so that
way Ukraine doesn't get their aid
because he's not going to shed a tear
that ukrainians are dying as they're
trying to protect their country now this
is the stupid [__] narrative that
somehow America
is aimlessly wasting money to defend
Ukraine when ukrainians can defend
themselves and even if they can't then
Russia should have it anyways like
that's their stupid [__] narrative
right I mean the reason why America is
protecting Ukraine and giving it
Aid We're not losing American lives okay
there's no American soldiers on the
ground so there's not there's not human
assets that are that are at stake here
this is just [__] money we're talking
about but this isn't just an investment
for Ukraine this is an investment for
our NATO allies because if if Putin does
take Ukraine now he's bordered to
Nato and that could be a [__] big
problem with our NATO allies in the
agreement that we have with NATO and I
don't know if you know the history of
NATO and what it what it means and
represents but more importantly what it
has made sure we don't have is a World
War breaking out in
Europe specifically in Eastern
Europe so when you're thinking about
this in the you know Nuance as Matt gats
can't think about nuance and again I go
back to is this really Matt Gat saying
this [__] is it I I mean how you
supposed to [__] know but we can only
trust what the [__] they're saying and
you know that Matt gatz is saying [__]
because he's an [__] he's an [__]
so let's listen to what the [__] has
to say about shutting down the your
government your
government yeah I gotta let me just say
this and I'm gonna kick it right to you
trash um is that you know there's a
again the sentiment out here in the in
the real world is that uh most of us on
the magas side are not in support of
this entire Ukraine debacle um and
there's something to be said for the
information War that's being had here um
so we're I think I I speak for a lot of
people when I say that uh we're glad
that you have that Outlook because it's
it's under represented uh you know from
the other politicians I'll just say it
that way Aaron trash please go ahead
okay so they're again they literally
have a a in this
in and you're wondering why I'm saying
question everything there's literally a
raccoon in this [__] Twitter space
called trash
discourse
okay on Twitter yes Mike's like what
what trash you're saying trash yeah what
no there is a
raccoon uh in the Twitter space I mean
I'm supposed to believe it's a raccoon
there's a goddamn picture of a raccoon
and the name of the account is trash
discourse
okay and the other thing too cofit over
on Discord points out a good thing cofit
says oh my God they're calling
themselves manga that is just hilarious
yes they refer to themselves as
manga they refer to and and that's why
it is so important that we mock MAA okay
it is super important that we mock manga
I actually have an article well I don't
I'm going to publish it
an article from AI Tony I Tony I'm going
to publish that article on patreon today
and it's talking about this condition
right now there was I don't know we
found we found this information and
we're gonna we're gonna have Tony write
a story on it but the story goes like
this um years ago when the clan had a
big hold on this country DC Comics put
out a Superman versus the clan
comic book where Superman right
Superman
was getting the clan the clan was the
bad guys in the comic book and Superman
was the hero right what happened was is
Children of
clansmen were putting on sheets and
playing Superman versus the clan okay
now when they were playing Superman
versus the clan because of because of
culture because of pop culture and
Superman was the hero he was the comic
book hero at the time in this
country when some kids were putting on
the sheets as the clan they weren't
putting on the sheets as if they were
proud to be Clan they were putting on
the sheets to mock the clan because
someone had to be the bad guy someone
had to be the loser and Superman was the
hero he was the winner in that
story and that's why it's so important
to mock these
fools because there are heroes there are
winners there are losers I hate to be
that way but it's
true and we have to mock them in a way
that makes them not want to be the
losers but you can see and that's a and
it's the point that Sickle fit I think
is trying to make over on Discord is
that they actually refer to themselves
even though we do proper mocking in
overdrive they still refer to themselves
as maanga they don't get that they're
the losers they don't get it so just be
aware of this stuff and not only that be
aware that there's United States House
Representatives um and here Eugene has
it here um it's an account on and I I
followed Eugene for a while he's had a
lot of different accounts he's been
banned a lot but here's his tweet he
said last night I listened to Lauren
bartt Matt gats and George Santos in a
space he's talking about Twitter space
they admitted their goal was to keep
America shut down and it was was said
they would do this through the next
election they also pointed out it would
keep money keep point it would keep
money flowing to Ukraine this is a coup
not an election
again they are holding your government
hostage and they are willing to keep the
government your government shut down
through the next ction so when I say
there is a possibility that we do not
have a
speaker between now and whene Jeff is
elected in January
2025 we may be a year and three months
we may be 14 15 months from having a
speaker of the
house I know it's like whoa [__] that is
is that a reality it absolutely is a
reality because if that's what they were
saying and I'm going to try to get some
better audio of this so we can really
figure out if these [__] boneheads
which I can't even believe that anyone
would show up in a Twitter space and
share Twitter space with George Santos
because there's [__] breaking news
right now that George
Santos is going is going to be arraigned
tomorrow on no excuse me on Friday
George Santos is going to be arraigned
on his new charges of identity theft of
stealing the credit cards of his of his
uh his donors he's going to be arraigned
on stealing their identities and money
on Friday and these [__] idiots are
showing up in a Twitter space you know
rubbing elbows with this some
[__] so does that say more about George
Santos or does that say more about
Lauren bobert
Matt Gatson Byron Donald's because I
guess Byron Donald's was in that space
too at some point I don't know if he's
in there with geord Santos but would you
want to go to a a
space and be on the side of listen would
you want to go to
anywhere not just a Twitter space but
would you want to go to
anywhere and be on the side of George
Santos in that
conversation huh [__] crazy ass
[__] it's a q andon
World we're just living in it I'm
telling you all right let's see H Scott
McFarland has the news on George Santos
let me read that to you now so you can
see that I'm not I'm not full of shite
when I say that he's going to be
arraigned on Friday here is uh here's
Scott McFarland here he says arraignment
uh on the superseding indictment in USA
vers George Santos is set for Friday a
federal court in the eastern district of
new in New York York in the meantime
representative Santos will have a vote
this week on choosing the next house
Speaker well congratulations to the
Republican party remember when
everyone's like oh he needs to resign he
needs to resign which I'm not
disagreeing um you know he is a scumbag
piece of [__] and he doesn't belong in
our Congress but here's the thing what I
said back then I said you know what he's
like all the Republicans anyways so why
would we want him to resign if we had to
him resign over lies then we have to
have all Republicans resign which you
know maybe that's not a bad idea I'm not
saying that ain't a bad idea um so I
want to give Eugene credit here for that
uh for that tweet where he's standing on
top and again he has the um he has the
audio but it's like hours long this was
like an hours long uh
space that they were talking in okay
there's that do we have do we have news
um from the house floor do we have news
from the house floor is there is there
going to be a vote today are they going
to call call the floor to order today
let's go check it out I doubt it I doubt
it they're not going to vote today
there's a apparently a a um a push for
and I think it I think it's
nine there's nine [__] that are
pushing for
um for speaker of the house they're
they're they're the ones running so they
went from no nobody to um Steve scalise
for 24 hours not even half the Congress
would vote for him um to now they're
they went to Jim Jordan Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan the three-time
loser on the house floor and it got
worse every single time to now for nine
nine more idiots these are the idiots
here actually you know what let's go to
this other graphic and I'll call out
their
names let's
see here here we go here's the uh here's
the nine idiots here they
are and you can kind of see that there's
a there's a Schism in the trend here but
you know that's the way it can go
sometimes um you know they got their one
toen black dude Byron Donalds as he is
but these are the nine Republicans that
are going to try to be speaker of the
house Speaker of the House oh speaker of
the
these guys do do you recognize any of
these I mean besides Byron Donald's
there is there anyone that you that you
recognize I'm I'm being serious type it
in the chat if you recognize any of
these idiots I mean I I can point out
two that I I can tell who they are now
right now let me show you the two this
guy over here this is sessions from um
from
Texas and then I believe he's from Texas
and then this guy from Georgia you
remember uh the I Nazi last week where
we weren't sure if it was AI or not on
CNN that's another thing that's coming
that's gonna scare the [__] out of you
this is Austin Scott or Scott Austin I
don't know it's hard I mean h how the
[__] are you supposed to tell a guy this
this [__] fake with two first names I
mean you know I you know I'm not going
to say a guy shouldn't have two first
names you know what I mean Tony and
Michael but you know
Austin Scott Scott Austin whatever the
hell his name is right there it is and
then Byron Donalds now you remember
Byron Donald's from back in January when
Kevin McCarthy was um was trying to get
elected speaker it took him 14 times and
the Republicans nominated Byron Donald's
one reason why is because he's one of
the only black dudes in their concus
literally in the house he's one of the
only black dudes in their concus but
they thought that they could use the
race card because hem Jeff was the very
first africanamerican man who was
nominated to be speaker and they thought
that they could that they could be oh
well you
wraith wraith you're race card you got
the race card but let me let me show you
or let me tell you who these people are
uh so I'll pull this back up here uh to
give you an idea of who these [__]
chuckleheads are okay
this is uh um let's see I gotta get this
straight Gary Palmer of
Alabama and then we're gonna go to um
Mike Johnson which that sounds fake of
Louisiana and then we have Tom emmer of
Minnesota and then we have let's see who
do we have here do we have Daniel um
muser meower Meer of Pennsylvania I
don't know what the [__] this guy's name
is and then Kevin he of
Oklahoma and then you have Pete Sessions
not to be confused by Jeff sessions who
was an a a senator and Donald Trump's
first failed attorney
general and then you have Byron Donald's
there and then you have Jack Bergman of
MI Michigan and then the final one there
is Austin Scott of Georgia that's the
roll
call that's the people right now
in the House of Representatives that
want to be
speaker now if you remember Austin Scott
went on CNN and absolutely embarrassed
himself he didn't even know how to count
he didn't know that that Republicans
were in the majority he didn't know what
a majority was and what a minority was
he didn't even know that that the the
[__] M majority has to select the
speaker he had no clue he had no [__]
clue um but this is here this is Liz
Cheney on CNN uh this weekend well hang
on that's the wrong that's the wrong
window godd damn it okay let's change
here um this is Liz Cheney over the
weekend now I'm very critical of Liz
Cheney as you know which you know you
should be everyone should be critical of
her it took her uh 190 days to come to
the house FL to admit that Trump had
lost officially on the record which is
the reason why I'm critical of here but
here she is on St of the Union on CNN
this this Sunday talking about these
nine chuckleheads of the candidates for
speaker Kevin Hearn Byron Donalds Mike
Johnson Jack Bergman all of them voted
to object to the Electoral College
results in Arizona and Pennsylvania and
to disenfranchise millions of Americans
based on those lies is that
disqualifying certainly I think there's
no question
and
uh again with this [__] [__] everyone
wents to make her a goddamn hero right
now she voted to certify the election
but she would not admit and she was
third in line to the power of the
speaker at the time folks in her caucus
well not the speaker but in her caucus
she was third there was one Kevin
McCarthy Steve scales and then Liz
Cheney was in the
leadership ladder of
leadership and she would it took her 190
days to admit it and now she's
saying on state of the union and you can
I'll play it again again you gotta
question everything but listen each of
the candidates for speaker Kevin Hearn
Byron Donalds Mike Johnson Jack Bergman
all of them voted to object to the
Electoral College results in Arizona and
Pennsylvania and to
disenfranchise millions of Americans
based on the those lies is that
disqualifying certainly I think
certainly it is disqualifying so does
that disqualify Liz Cheney because she
wouldn't
admit that she wouldn't admit it until
190 days it took her 190 days you go
count the days I mean I'm not making
that [__] up go count the days and then
go look at the floor speech I did a
video about
it so I mean you
know and and and they want to know why
the Republican party is in
disarray well this is
why this is why it's in
disarray because they capitulated to
these [__] idiots for so
long and they
continue to capitulate to this [__]
idiot
he runs the house
caucus he is the Maga King matter of
fact you know what we we have a um we've
got an update on the George
Santos uh story here we've got a picture
of George Santos um he's preparing to
get ready for his um for his appearance
on Friday for his arrangment I don't
want to uh want to make sure everyone
has this here is George Santos getting
ready for his arraignment oh my
god oh [__] there's George Santos
getting ready for his
arraignment on Friday looks like he's
got a few um credit cards there with
[Music]
[Laughter]
him oh boy oh you know what Shaz is
actually mad let's go to Shaz here he
says go away Liz Cheney stop giving her
TV time does that mean that I should
play more clips of Liz Cheney just to
get Shaz in his Fields Shaz is scared of
L
Cheney oh Shaz is terrified of this
Cheney you're such a
[__] oh you don't don't give her TV
time see that's what these that's what
these losers
do is they believe that we're that we
are so stupid that can't see through Liz
Cheney hey Chez if you're here long
enough you'll know that I know Liz
Cheney is on your
side on your
side on your you know the side that
wants to take away women's right to
health care and their right to privacy
inside their doctor's office she wants
to do that yeah Liz Cheney ain't on our
[__] side Liz Cheney wants to wants
to get rid of Social Security and
Medicare she do like those things she's
on your [__] side Chez she's one of
you you dumb
[__] Liz Cheney is not our friend as
liberals she is not a liberal she wants
to take Liberty away from people in this
country she literally wants to smash up
women's healthare rights with a [__]
hammer and she definitely does not want
them to have privacy in their own
doctor's office between them and their
doctor so Liz Cheney can get [__] as
far as I'm concerned and Shaz you can
[__] have her okay me as a liberal in
this country as someone who beles
believes and [__] Liberty freedom and
rights I don't want anything to do with
[__] Liz Cheney not a goddamn thing
and anyone who acts like she's some kind
of [__] hero because she did the bare
minimum and admit that Trump lost the
election only 190 days after he lost
that [__] election
well excuse the [__] out of me it should
have been the bare minimum of every
goddamn Republican at this point to
speak out against this [__] and say he
[__] lost you [__] crybabies quit
your [__] whining in your bitching
grow a [__] pair and admit that he's
a [__] loser and move
on move on to some other [__] fascist
that you want to support
and we'll Crush that son of a [__] too
we will beat them at The Ballot
Box telling you Liz Cheney is not our
friend and Shaz you can [__] have her
she's one of you dummy she's one of
yours she's one of you she was maanga
before you were MAA you dumb
bastard let's
see
[Music]
um let's see what else do we got
here do we got any other news I don't
know I like the picture of George Santos
don't you like the new the news George
Santos look I like it see this is the
[__] we can do with AI and it's only
gonna get better and faster it really is
oh my God it's gonna get better faster
oh my god oh let me show you some freak
out here oh this is really gonna trigger
Chad Shaz
Shaz in the shart Army this is really
going to [__] trigger him RNC
research put out this [__] video oh
my God it's terrifying you should see it
you should see it it's [__]
terrifying I can't even believe that
this is real maybe it's not but it could
be oh my God but they're
terrified oh my God they're terrified of
this and this is gonna scare CH Chez You
Know You're Gonna Want to strap in here
buddy this is some terrifying video of
the president of United States it's it's
crazy
[__] it's Insanity that this is even
happening here is here is Joe
Biden oh my God he's walking with his
wife on the beach look at this look at
[Music]
this he's walking on the beach what is
he doing he's destroying America look at
him oh my God it's the waves crash in oh
get rid of him and Peach Joe bid imp
Peach him oh my God look at him look at
him he can
walk he can walk in the sand oh my God
it's so scary literally RNC
research posted that and it's supposed
to [__] it's supposed to [__]
terrify you I don't know Shad says look
I told you I told you it'd trigger him I
told you it'd trigger him wow Americans
are suffering and Biden is enjoying his
little vacation it's called a weekend
you dumb [__] do you take a
weekend come on are we supposed to
believe that Donald Trump has never
taken [__] time off that's all he
took time off from the only time when he
was working that was his time off from
taking time off you know what the [__] I
mean you know what I'm talking about
that lazy piece of fat trash and then
Ronda santz sh your guy that you love oh
my God you love suckling at the teeth of
that Florida fascist shz Ronda santis
that [__] is in another state
every goddamn day of the week even
though he's
losing he ain't got no [__] money and
he ain't got no personality and he ain't
got enough [__] money to buy a
personality Shaz you are so [__] full
of [__] I love when you come here man I
love your [__] com comments they're
so easy you just set the [__] ball up
on the te I knock it out of the park
every time every [__] time good for
you keep coming back every day we missed
you here but literally I'm not [__]
you I wouldn't [__] you you're my
favorite turd this is this is the
RNC putting this stuff out look at this
they said Americans are still being held
hostage by Hamas terrorists even though
the United States and the Biden
Administration negotiated for two
American hostages uh from near Chicago
to go across the Egyptian border from
Hamas oh y mm yep they sure did they're
actually doing the [__] that the RNC is
accusing him not of doing and Joe Biden
is at the beach oh my God he's taking a
[__] walk holy
[__] what a bunch of [__] [__]
what a bunch of godamn
[__] that they believe that some
somehow our country isn't safe because
the American president takes 10 minutes
out of his [__] Sunday to take a walk
with his wife on the beach you people
are [__] dumb as dog [__] if you
believe this makes our country unsafe or
some [__] whatever the [__] you're
talking
about this the dumbest [__] I've ever
heard of you kidding me that somehow
somehow we should be scared cuz he's
taking a walk on the beach good God I
could give you just hours of footage of
trump with his golf club up his [__]
ass while he was the president of the
United States okay which I'm actually
not saying that a president of the
United States shouldn't
golf I'm not saying that a president of
United States shouldn't take a walk
every [__] day honestly they better
be taking a walk every goddamn day and
clearing some thoughts out of their damn
brain there's a lot of [__] they got to
deal with and it's one thing that Joe
Biden is damn good at he can walk and
chew gum without losing his shoes at the
same goddamn
time the guy can handle the country even
when he takes a little walk on the beach
you [__]
[__] manga is such a bunch of Crybaby
[__] aren't they Jesus Christ I've
never seen such [__] [__] in my
goddamn life trigger
triggered by a dude walking with his
wife on a beach on a Sunday afternoon
after they just got out of church
probably you [__]
break these people are such
scumbags the shart Army is full of
[__] scumbags and they're terrified
of that
footage so scary
Joe Biden he he takes walks on the
beach oh my God what the [__] is next
did you hear Joe Biden eats three times
a
day what the hell is our country coming
to oh my God he eats breakfast lunch and
dinner takes time out of his day they
can't even get a speaker of the
house they can't can't even get a
[__] speaker of the
house and they're bitching about Biden
taking a walk all at the same time
bitching about American hostages when
they just got two American hostages
across the Egyptian border the [__] are
you talking
about good
Lord boy oh boy boy boy I mean literally
they're just absolutely
absolutely and and if you go look at the
quote tweets it's all Republicans quote
tweeting that [__] oh yeah he's evil imp
peach in me and me Joe
Biden impeach Tre dish
him what a bunch of scumbags but you
know that's what happens and you know
it's it's funny because um have you guys
seen the Twitter account Biden
HQ oh my God it's actually the official
um one of the official campaign Twitter
accounts and they actually opened up
um a a fraud Social account just go [__]
with Donald Trump no I'm serious it's an
official just just a [__] with them um
but here here's the and it's a pretty
good Twitter account to follow even
though Twitter's the dumpster fire um if
you want to follow the dark Brandon
account because it's kind of like the
dark Brandon account but it's the
official one like literally here's
here's here's what it looks like it says
Malarkey ends here the Malarkey ends
here and it's Biden HQ is all it is
Biden headquarters but it's there it
says just the facts Jack a project of
Biden Harris 2024 but they post all
kinds of Clips which is kind of good um
so you can get you can get some of these
clips there here's for instance here's
one Dan Dan muser one of the one of
those [__] nine idiots that I showed
you earlier um here he is on Fox
Business let's see what he had well look
very unfortunately we're now part of the
dysfunction of Washington yes well look
dysfunction of Washington say say that
again say that again very unfortunately
we're now part of the disfunction of
Washington oh okay so it has nothing to
do with Joe Biden walking on a beach it
has with you [__] can't do your
job okay yeah got it it's clear now
we'll put it on the list a bunch of
[__]
they're the ones running around can't
get a speaker right and they're the same
ones running around bitching and Biden's
taking a walk on the beach are you
[__] kidding
me a bunch of dumb [__] oh shaz's
showing his true colors here I told you
he was with Liz Cheney I told you I told
you you're a Liz Cheney type Chez Shez
Liz Cheney wants to ban abortion she
really does she's on your side on that
it's really [__] weird that you know
so I mean you're asking can we ban
abortion I mean Liz Cheney wants to
she's on your side she's one of you
that's why I'll never [__] claim her
as a hero [__] her [__] Liz Cheney don't
come at me oh well she helped go against
Trump I don't give a [__] she' take your
goddamn rights away that's enough for me
to say I don't care who she tried to
stop taking people's [__] rights away
I don't think so not going to happen
here's a here's another report let's see
what what we got here this is on the
Biden can't even act upon it until the
speaker is elected a fight among House
Republicans it's shocking totally
shocking yeah they can't they can't do
anything until they get a speaker see
that's why I don't understand why people
keep talking about Patrick McHenry he
can't be the [__] speaker there's no
mechanism to make him the fake speaker
they have to elect a speaker and they're
going to shut down the government
because they're not going to have a
speaker and it is likely that they will
get four five six people to not elect
the speaker and till after the election
the next election like the next one like
next [__]
year um here is representative Collins
uh on his party's inability to govern
let's listen grow up this is not the way
to run a government you're not going to
do this and and right now we've got to
get a a oh yeah grow up on good luck
when the when the when the Chillin are
talking to the Chillin you know you feel
me
well who the [__] is another Republican
like Collins to tell people to grow up
are you serious then leave your party
then you dumb
[__] relinquish your R that's
what that's the only thing that's going
to solve this thing that's it the only
thing that's going to solve this
thing is if they start leaving the
party
okay they got to start leaving the party
and form their own party that's what
they're going to have to do but you know
what would happen if that happened think
about this okay think about this for a
second if the if the
non non Maga or the
grownups as Collins put it
Maga right if that was the
case
okay and they split off and they all
left the Republican party let's say they
could get 70 of them to defect to start
their own party their own National Party
do you know who the speaker in the house
would
be it'd be a Keem Jeff because Keem Jeff
would be the only one that had the
possibility of getting because then we'd
have three parties but AEM Jeff would
have the most votes so surely he could
get a couple people to vote for him
right and we could form a government so
they're not going to do
that they're not going to do that
because we have a two-party system
there's a
majority and the minority it's two
parties now that doesn't mean it has to
be Republican and Democrat that is not
what a two-party system means there's
just the majority and the
minority the Republican party is dead
it's not a real party but somehow they
gerrymandered their way into having the
majority in Our House of
Representatives and and they are no
longer a party because they're
controlled by an autocrat they're
controlled by a cult leader they're
controlled by one man all this is
because of one [__] Donald
Trump and just strap in and realize that
and just go with it because that's
it uh let's see here let's see what we
got here this is um who the [__] is this
guy Ron
Brownstein oh God Ron Brownstein this
guy it sound this guy really honestly
you know what I think uh R can we can we
make sure when we finally get um AI
Tony can we put him can we put him in
like front of a bookshelf that's really
what I want to do like just books you
know what I mean and let's pick out some
books that are [__] books but some that
are halfway decent you know what I mean
I
mean AI Tony definitely reads and he
probably reads books I'm sure and he
probably reads everything and it makes
him the smartest thing ever in the
history of ever if he reads stuff you
know what I'm saying if he reads things
so we really want to make it look like
this here where they're so smart because
they read um you know I look at my
bookshelves back here I got a few books
look at that one two three I got three
books back there that's George Carlin
that's what those books are I'm serious
those are George Carlin books those are
the only [__] books you need anyways
right I mean that's the only books you
need is George Garland books in the
first place but I really want to make it
look like AI Tony is really smart so
thank you rat make sure we make notes of
that
okay let's go to Ron here on CNN let's
see what his his great analysis here I'm
sure it's just um breathtaking it is
worth noting that even though emmer
voted to certify the result John he
joined the lawsuit you'll remember The
Longshot lawsuit from the state of Texas
seeking to overturn the election results
in four states 105 House Republicans
signed on to a brief supporting that he
was one of them as was Austin Scott the
other uh member who uh voted to certify
and is and is seeking the speakership so
there really is no one in this race who
did not in some way deny the validity of
Joe Biden's victory in 2020 it Hey Ron
There's A Better Way say they tried to
overturn our government they tried to
steal your vote away from you
is what they tried to do and they tried
to do a lot of different ways oh Sydney
pal Sydney pal shaz's American hero as
he puts it tried to steal the election
down in Georgia she she's admitted to
six different charges of election
interference of trying to steal the
election in Georgia so they tried to
steal an election they didn't just not
believe or whatever the
[__] they tried to steal your vote they
wanted to steal an election I wish the
media would get better at this I really
wish they
would it would be so much easier if they
would be better now here's here's Tim
Scott um N I don't want I don't want to
listen him on that never mind uh here is
here is Speaker McCarthy yesterday I
Meet the Press um the former ex-speaker
he's the ex-girlfriend in the House of
Representatives as it were here we go
here's Kevin McCarthy there one
this is a this is embarrassing for the
Republican party it's embarrassing for
the nation and we need to look at one
another well you're an embarrassment so
it's not surprising like literally it is
it is not
surprising you're an
embarrassment and you used to be the
speaker and you did the thing where you
couldn't do is you couldn't cross Trump
and cross him and you did you kept the
government open and that's not allowed
here in the United States here's
representative Mike Turner let's see if
if he thinks there'll be a speaker
unlike then here he is with respect to
the National Security clearly having a
house that's not function is is
certainly a security threat for our
country oh well I'm glad the Republicans
agree that them not being able to select
a speaker is affecting our national
security oh it's not Biden walking on
the
beach Jesus Christ these people but this
is what they do this is what they're
going to continue to do do we have any
word um here oh the the chat is saying
that I should put some ban books on my
bookshelf you guys want some baned books
on the
bookshelf actually you know what um if
you go to the library of democracy the
library of democracy has a bookstore
that you guys can buy B books uh let me
put that in the chat here and we're
going to be doing more more videos with
the library of democracy now here here
is the library democracy's YouTube
channel you guys should go follow the
library democracy but if you go to their
their YouTube channel their link tree is
right there and you can go to their
bookstore and there's ban books on their
bookstore and if you buy the ban books
on the library of democracy's bookstore
then it supports the library of
democracy so go check out speaking of
ban books go check out the library
democracy's YouTube channel click on
their link tree and and help the library
of democracy we're going to be doing a
lot of different things next year we're
starting to break down um the project
2025 I plan on having a guest this week
on Project 2025 we're going to talk
about project 20225 and what it means
and how it started and what the
historical context is you guys keep
hearing about this project 2025 but no
one actually says where the historical
context comes from and I think that's
that's important uh to know so let's go
let's go back to see if we can find some
more clips of people reacting uh of how
bad it is that that the Republican isn't
it funny how they're just re re
realizing that they're in the Republican
party isn't it funny it's kind of
[__] weird but um here's here's one
of here's a here's one of shaz's shart
Army here we go here's one of shaz's
shart Army here she is let's take a
listen what what does she have to say
about you know the speaker in the
president of United States let's listen
Donald Trump's a commander-in-chief what
what not now but not now sure he is yeah
we have a resident who's the the
president the installed president in the
white house we also have a commander-in
chief Biden runs the DC the 10 square
mile area in DC Trump's running the rest
of the show but he did do what what did
she say did she say did she say he's the
commander-in chief but Joe Biden just
controls 10 square miles or
what the what the [__] what the [__] is
she talking about let's see let's see if
she makes some sense here I doubt it
he's not like he's not even he is but he
is he's not even privy to that
intelligence oh yes he is how is he
privy to it when the president has not
shared all it's a military operation oh
Trump is behind a military op operation
that's going to make this correction yes
he is and where is where did how do we
know this yeah uh let's see you can
start doing research um yeah go you know
what you should do you know you should
do go ask Shaz on Facebook he'll tell
you he'll take him and his sh Army will
tell you holy
[__] this is this is real oh we got
another hang on hang on a second we got
another we got another breaking uh
picture of um there's some more
photographs of George Santos preparing
for his uh preparing for his arrangment
on Friday so here's uh he looks like
he's he's he's saying some prayers here
looks like if you see there he's saying
some prayers for his arrangment on
Friday but he still he still got that
money money that chinga CH Ching that
chinga chinga Ching chinga chinga Santos
chinga CH chinga I don't know if these
are his his previous donors credit cards
that he already stole the money off of
or if these are new ones I don't know uh
maybe we we'll see if we can get a
um an answer from his press his press
staff but he's he's praying he's praying
for himself and he's praying that
everything goes well see that the clown
Bible no
boy the clown Bible I I don't know
exactly how AI makes these things but
aren't they spoton look at that aren't
they spoton I mean this that's pretty
goddamn close right I'm not GNA GNA lie
that's pretty close the AI is pretty
intelligent oh boy oh boy you're a bad
rat you rat bastard you rat
bastard we love we love H small rat here
thank you small rat for all the for all
the laughter thanks for all the stuff
today we appreciate it it's clo it's
getting to be about closing time but I
want to tell you guys that rant here
he's going to be joining us in the
background a lot maybe one of these days
um he'll join us on on screen and you'll
hear him talk and and see him his mouth
move it's a real rat I'm telling you
it's an actual rat you're real you're
real right uh small rat is real he's a
real rat and and you know what um he was
talking yesterday uh in the chat on uh
the patreon only Sunday rant and if you
guys want to get in on the Sunday rant
you just go to patreon just go to the
dony michaels.com hit the patreon link
and you can join in on the Sunday rant
there you got to be a paid member to
join the Sunday rant but you should
follow for free on patreon but he he let
everyone know that he has a new section
on the Discord and anyone in the Discord
listening uh there's a rat Army I know
Shaz has a shart Army but small rat is
developing a rat Army over on Discord
and he needs your help with links of
video
rather it's videos of this show which
you should do you should definitely go
over and you should
definitely put in timestamps for this
show that are your favorite timestamps
that's really kind of the idea whatever
your favorite timestamps for this show
is it'll go over there and it'll give
suggestions for clips that way we can
make longer clips and then the shorts
that that skip does he's going to be
able to make more of them faster so it's
going to be fantastic so go go over and
go to the hashtag rat Army timestamps
rat Army t timestamps on the Discord let
me give you the um let me give you the
link here to Discord I'm telling you
this Discord thing it's like our own
little social media if you want to know
what it is and it and at first it it
feels like it's hard to learn but it's
really easy I promise you if you
download the app and go use the the the
app to log in it's really easy it's easy
stuff it's our own little social media
page over there it's only us talking to
each other
it really is nice um pazzi says bye Tony
I'll see you later pazzi I'm glad that
you get the get you got Jo everyone tell
pep Razzi goodbye one of the fan fans
here I I love you pep pep Razzi so go
everyone give a goodbye to to pazzi and
I you know that's the other thing I want
to talk about while we're wrapping up
here you guys are so supportive of each
other you really are um it's so it's so
great Jesse says clip for skip yep
you're gonna help rat find these clips
for skip as the rat Army and we're going
to play games there's a new arcade
section on Discord too and that's what I
was going to say it's like you guys are
so supportive of each other that's why
we want to do more in the Discord
because it's like a community over there
and it's like our own little social
media our own little cornet social media
without algorithms without them beating
a bunch of [__] fascist trash on
Twitter or Facebook filling your your
whole beat up with all kinds of [__]
it's just people talking to people over
there it's Community we're building
there's some cool stuff over there you
can put your you know like food that
you're finding if you're a foodie if you
like to take pictures a lot of people
are posting pictures that they're taking
when they're out and about uh and
sharing their art sharing stuff they
make with us over there you can vote for
bonehead of the week like we have the
boneh of the week every single week you
can vote over there um you're going to
be able to see all the shorts first
there's a section where they're
automatically posted once they go live
Live on YouTube you can be the first to
see them over on Discord and there's
going to be games there's arcade games
if you want if you want to join the
patreon you can there's a a patreon chat
and then you can join the patreon
producers Corner if you join the $20
tier on patreon um so there's all kinds
of great stuff to do over there and
we're going to be giving out rewards too
so as you play games and as you do
things we're going to have like points
and stuff so you guys can just have fun
over there because we want to create our
own little space and we do have a
community over there going
uh so if you're not in the Discord you
should really figure out a way to join
in and I promise it's not that hard to
learn whether you're on mobile or you're
on the computer uh and once you get in
there you'll learn it's almost it's
almost as easier easier than Twitter so
just go to the link that I put in the
chat to the Discord and what you'll be
able to do is you go to the Welcome
Center and click the green check mark go
to the Welcome Center and click the
green check mark at the bottom of the
Box there's an arrow it says click this
box and you just click the the green
check mark and that verifies you so make
sure to click the green check mark in
the Welcome Center and that verifies you
and then you can get in and you can ask
all kinds of questions and it's it's a
great place and everyone will be welcome
there that we we don't keep the trash
around in the Discord so it's a it's a
great community that we have going there
I'm so glad you joined me here on Monday
it's been a great show it's been a great
day I had fun uh watching the Biden and
if you want to watch more of that the
the Biden vers Trump just go just go to
YouTube and type in Biden vers Trump Ai
and it'll pop up and you guys will see
those videos so go check that out go
check out AI Jesus make sure to go to
patreon go to dton michaels.com go to
patreon it's free to follow me we're
going to be posting more articles from I
Tony the AI Tony we'll be posting more
of those as soon as we get them up and
running so check those out there I
appreciate you so much you're the best
audience in the world tell the mods
thank you as you leave because they're
the best moderators in the world whether
you're on Facebook YouTube our twitch
our Discord love all of you same time
same place tomorrow Surfs Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podast in your
face commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow Tony
on social media at thee Tony Michaels
and until next time raise a fist and
repeat after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's meor head ass
speaking
I'm going to veto everything he tries to
do I'm gonna cut off his dick and shove
it up his ass so far he'll be [__]
out his own balls enough is enough with
this [__] for people wonder
ideas when it comes to his Web of Lies
and deception I'm going to cut off his
dick and shut covered up his ass so far
he'll be [__] out his own balls
enough is enough with this [__]
this dark Brandon time [__] get out
of my
way chiso Trump doesn't need supersonic
abilities to win we have the biggest and
most tremendous brains in the world
Biden is confused believe me chriso he's
been lost for years you want a Super
Saiyan fight kiso come at us bro Trump
will bury you with the bigest words ever
spoken
[__] supersonic abilities we've got
something better we've got me the Biden
eye I'm going to unleash a [__] storm
on all of you you don't know what I mean
folks you better strap in because it's G
to be a wild [__]
ride let me tell you
Trump